la semaine des collections de la mode de
l'hiver prochain commence alors qu'on
arrive tout juste au printemps cela se
passe dans la cour carrée du loup la
cour rénovée elle sort tout juste de ces
travaux il ya beaucoup de japonais
beaucoup d'américains pour acheter puis
il ya françois chez dan moussa l'eau
pour les observer ça y est après
plusieurs années de travaux la mode a
retrouvé sa que la cour carrée du mans
évidemment il y a encore quelques
bulldozers farsi quelques pelleteuse par
là mais nul n'est parfait et puis les
inaugurations c'est comme ça on n'a
jamais fini mais on va garer les
ouvriers derrière les plantes vertes et
on n'y verra que du feu
stocker des roms
publique internationale et bariolés
comme de coutume chacun cet effet son
propre spectacle
on avait le look le vrai évidemment côté
météo ce n'est pas ça mais chantal
thomass avait bien prévu elle avait
envoyé ses invitations en forme de
fiches et plastiques en écrivant
j'espère qu'il va pleuvoir
elle a gagné d'autres ont trouvé des
vrais parapluie certains ont pris des
chaises ça faisait aussi abri contre la
pluie et on est parti sous les tentes
pour garder la mode divers 86 86
et là on a oublié la météo au milieu de
fumée des feux de lumières ce furent des
collections d'hiver
il sentait le brin coquine sexy et à
guichen chantal thomass les ventes et
les gamines perverse qui porte une
guêpière redoutent le cartable des
poupées des danseuses de cordes des gens
vous montrer très haut gainées de toiles
d'araignées ou volantée sur le volet des
lili marlène auquel il ne manque que les
fouets
et un nouveau lainage expansible qui me
la fina perçu ni à creuse
sous une boule géante où nagent année
plus une autre styliste féminine
japonaise junko shimada nous a ouvert
elle aussi des perspectives coquine jupe
fendue ultracourte uniforme sado maso et
même sous des velours de fausses hanches
émouvante
enfin des tricots si doux qu'il
n'appelle pas là car s ils exigent en or
à chaud le prochain hiver
en tout cas chaud au coeur